merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs madame la
Présidente assassin vous avez évoqué
trois sujets plusieurs sujets pardon
notamment des sujets de fonds le débat
sur les articles et sur les amendements
nous permettra très certainement d'y
revenir si tenter que la motion n'était
pas adoptée donc nous aurons j'espère en
tout cas l'occasion de vous convaincre
que cette réforme est à la fois juste
qu'elle porte des progrès et qu'elle est
nécessaire je voudrais simplement
revenir sur trois points d'abord la
question de la recevabilité que vous
avez souligné mais madame le rapporteur
général de la commission des affaires
sociales comme madame la Présidente on
soulignait à quel point les dispositions
nous vous présentons ont un impact en
des conséquences sur les comptes sociaux
pour l'année 2023 ce qui justifie le
fait d'avoir recours à un projet de loi
de financement de la sécurité sociale
rectificative pour l'année 2023 vous
avez ensuite madame la Présidente
considérer que la mise en œuvre de
l'article 47-1 pouvait poser une
difficulté je voudrais rappeler deux
choses la première c'est que si nous
sommes dans le cadre de l'article 47-1
ce n'est pas une décision du
gouvernement l'article 47 terrain
s'applique à l'ensemble des lois de
finances et la récente organique que
votre assemblée a adopté comme
l'Assemblée nationale dit que lorsque
les lois de finances rectificatives pour
la sécurité sociale comme pour l'État
relève de la catégorie des lois de
finances et donc Stones sous le coup de
l'article 47-1 cet article 47-1 fixe un
certain nombre délais il ne prévoit ni
dérogation ni possibilité d'aller
au-delà et donc nous l'appliquons de
manière stricte mais cela a été rappelé
aussi cette application de l'article 47
terrain le respect de l'article 47-1
plus exactement permet au Parlement
d'avoir un délai d'examen de cette
réforme plus long que le délai
parlementaire consacré aux réforme des
retraites précédentes et enfin Madame la
Présidente vous avez considéré qu'il
n'était pas opportun d'examiner un texte
qui n'aurait pas été adopté par
l'Assemblée nationale les différentes
dispositions que j'ai rappelé permettent
cet examen et organise un tel examen et
je voudrais simplement revenir d'un mot
sur les raisons qui ont amené à
l'Assemblée nationale à ne pas pouvoir
examiner totalement le texte à ne pas
pouvoir voter cette raison ne tient un
seul tient un seul mot l'obstruction
l'obstruction avec 20 000 amendements
qui ont été dé posés et des séries
d'amendements identiques imaginez madame
la Présidente et je sais que ça
n'arrivera pas ici mais imaginez madame
la Présidente que
le dernier jour du débat le dernier jour
du débat il y avait 68 séries
d'amendements identiques déposés par le
groupe de la France insoumise avec mon
collègue Gabriel Attal nous avons mais
vous êtes leurs alliés mais avec mon
collègue Gabriel Attal nous avons écouté
patiemment 68 intervenants différents du
groupe de la France insoumise avant même
de pouvoir donner un avis et alors même
que l'amendement ne concernait pas le
fond du texte c'est la description de ce
que j'ai appelé l'obstruction et ce qui
explique la situation que nous
connaissons pour toutes ces raisons bien
évidemment la vie est défavorable
merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]